he him she her that's broke
Z Zim z-zer
that is woke
but I am
that is
bespoke there are some viral tick tocks
on all the new pronouns and because now
we as as the comment of the day pointed
out we no longer teach the kids the
birds and the bees we teach them the
zuras and the Z's let's hear the
pronouns I'm Cody pronouns
emsers or really any nail pronouns that
aren't Z Hair hers
this
is amazing I had not seen this I could
have anticipated it but I had not seen
this yet Z her hers
that's now stodgy that's old fuddy-duddy
that's oppressive
now you got to be em air ears
not Z not z z e her hers
z-e her hers very old-fashioned how dare
you doesn't really describe reality
Stephen Pinker
describe something called the euphemism
treadmill
and the euphemism treadmill is this idea
that when people are describing things
that have negative associations they
will come up with a new word for this is
what political correctness is he was a
what he was a so I come
with a new word and that new word is
supposed to paper over the negative
connotation so for instance an illegal
alien we don't call them illegal aliens
anymore we call them illegal immigrants
they're immigrants they're the other
illegal but they're still immigrants we
like immigrants and then illegal
immigrant took on that connotation so
they say okay this person is
undocumented
then undocumented
took on a negative connotation they
became undocumented Americans they're
obviously not Americans but they're
another undocumented Americans then that
took on a negative connotation then we
call them dreamers oh they're dreamers
we are the dreamers of dreams and you
know that's going to take on a negative
connotation too and they're gonna have
to come up with a new one so that's
exactly what's going on here Z her hers
has become a punch line it's just refers
to people who are confused you yes not
you him what's your name me yes you I am
me here's me and I'm you people know
that and so now they say no no forget
about Z her her hers now we gotta be
right now go to expressvpn.com Michael
Knowles show let me ask you something
when you use the restroom you always
close the door behind you right you
don't want random passersby looking in
on you so why would you let people look
in on you when you go online
using the internet without expressvpn is
like going to the restroom and not
closing the door okay I love expressvpn
I'm a total Luddite so I barely know how
to use any technology but it's so easy
to use even I can use it you just
download it one click of a button on
your cell phone on your laptop on your
on your iPad on whatever you want I can
say with full confidence expressvpn is
the best VPN on the market here's why
number one expressvpn doesn't log your
online activity they even developed a
trusted server technology that makes it
impossible for their servers to store
any data at all number two speed
expressvpn does not slow down your user
experience you can stream HD videos with
zero buffering number three expressvpn
is incredibly easy to use
it's that one button you're done you're
good to go if you're like me you believe
your online activity is your business
use our link expressvpn.com Michael
Knowles show today get three months free
on a one-year package
expresvpn.com Michael nolesshow
expressvpn.com Michael Knowles show okay
keep going I am a white transmasculine
Femme non-binary temporarily mostly
able-bodied neurodivergent obsessive
compulsive chronically ill culturally
Jewish Unitarian Universalist
non-monogamous a culturally Jewish that
was just what we were discussing about
the difference between transgenderism
and Judaism is people say how on Earth
can you be Jewish but not be not believe
in God well it's because of that because
you can say well I'm ethnically
associated with this tribe but I'm I'm
religiously I don't I don't believe in
that at all and it's why this is why
people who hate the Jews go astray I
think is because there is a huge
difference
there is a a much bigger difference
between someone who believes in God and
someone who doesn't believe in God then
there is a difference between people of
any different races keep going
hello romantic great mabeth sexual
Survivor of acute and complex trauma
Millennial is and Cat parent in mental
health recovery why are we still here
[Music]
you know the worst part here
cat parent obviously that's
unless you are a cat
you cannot be a cat parent and if you
think you are a cat parent that's a
symptom of something worse and this
company still doesn't recognize cat
maternity and so the person says I'm in
mental health recovery I hope that's
true I mean I hope this person's getting
help but if you're saying that
especially publicly it doesn't look like
you're in recovery it seems like you
need to get a new psychologist screw you
I'm not going to help make it better
next
[Music]
that's interesting my kitten's a furry
not pansexual or transsexual or
buy say or whatever those are my kitten
I think my kitten is a furry and I think
my kitten might be the only only actual
furry out there no I'm just kidding I
don't have a kitten I'm a people person
[Music]
I got it